partner horoscope signs I'm looking for
a connection energy trauma toxic
masculinity my truth healing
narcissistic ex-boyfriend abusive
ex-boyfriend great accusation with no
evidence don't judge yeah but
manifesting equals I want to do no work
and get the outcome as a woman I did too
much and I let him walk all over me
equals I like cheaters and toxic men and
I will choose them and be toxic as well
and not admit that I had any part to
play except hashtag giving too much
generational trauma I make the same
mistakes that my parents made and I'm
too dumb to learn from their mistakes
and instead I will blame the same
mistake and I will make the same mistake
and blame it on them in my feminine
energy men always stare and approach me
I will be submissive for the right man
men are trash equals I take no
accountability for the negative part
that myself or any woman play in
relationships he needs to make six
figures equals I have no emphasis on
character I don't need a man but I want
a man my ring needs to cost this much
Financial of abuse I became feminine I
need a man to maintain you we need to
Vibe I feel like I'm traditional
um when I have done no work to become
traditional Manish I will be submissive
for the right man who hurt you
internalize misogyny I am leveling up
together I need a man to be on my level
level Boss B I'm a bad [__] these men
are broken Dusty
he needs to add he needs to add to what
I have going on in my life not all women
equals that is a problem with women but
I won't admit it's a problem
um I need someone to match my energy I
am his peace
I read it better than I read the super
chats because I've spent a lot of time
writing that sometimes you wrote it and
because of the letters people spell
things wrong in the Super Chat okay
because they don't you only get so many
characters so you're kind of making out
what they say right anyways you should
have a cocky today you know like start
the clock somebody yeah yeah anyway so
[Music]
all right
and I just want to say women say men are
F boys but how do you know he's a f boy
if you didn't let him F yes so does that
make you a f girl does it make you easy
does it make you for the street you
don't want a man to say you for the
street but you can call him an F boy I
don't deal with f boys so like women who
who protect their box they're not
dealing with that energy but if you've
been effed and ran through you have to
say to yourself I've allowed this man to
be a f boy to my most precious my most
precious possession on The Dating Market
which is my womb my body and it we say
you know my body my choice and don't
objectify me but a lot of times we
objectify ourselves the way we dress the
way we present and then we we blame a
man but like I never heard the term F
boy until I start getting on Tick Tock
and I dealt in these spaces and I'm like
well why did you let him hunch on you
no no they need to say that
[Music]
[Laughter]
he hit me harder than I hit him oh damn
it's still a hit what about body
positivity like is that sort of mainly
for a specific body or is that it's only
for women it's only for women where
where have you seen a 300 pound man on
the front of Cosmo or any other magazine
it's only for women and and you will see
the same women who will put down men or
shame them for their height but where's
your body positivity for a man who's
five feet tall but you want a man to
accept you as you are accept him as he
is but see it's it's not equal
broke man positivity trust me I'm
positive
listen I want to talk about this as well
and I know like you know the guys
actually it was only one other guy here
but you know from from my perspective
um
like you know as a as a young boy right
like and you're watching these shows on
TV where they're talking about a man a a
man's member the size matter like how
dare you how how how the nerve of you
cowards to get up on TV and to talk
about on daytime talk show TV and to
talk about the size matter does your
viscous in this matter yeah because
because
y'all are just as different which jaw
insides as we are different with our
outsides so y'all could judge all this
ever in terms of size depth
circumference where it's actually
positioned we're adding small dick
energy
because we talk about the pH we talk
about the smell and somebody that's from
a genetic perspective as well but like
the the actual oil on the inside of it
like it's it's a lot different as well
so like if it doesn't go right it
doesn't all have to do with his member
you know but to talk about that it
happens young boys listening to that
sometimes maybe because it's damaging
maybe that's what it is because the
women always say that the man's dick is
too small but the women never say my fan
is too big
is the body positivity they will claim
the same body positivity I can be 500
pounds and accept me as I am but the
same woman will claim small D energy was
something that's genetic where if you
controlled how much you ate and you
exercise and discipline yourself you can
actually control doesn't mean to be a
supermodel in a size you know I don't
know in the UK with the sizes are but
like size two and zero like super skinny
but a lot of men aren't even looking for
that but you will claim body positivity
but the same woman will say you got
small D energy I'm not even talking
about that I'm talking about I want my
mother always say oh he didn't satisfy
me because dick small but you never had
man say uh funny was too big I was
rolling around in it
there was so much air rushing around
yeah you know yeah
I have a really great um addition to
this list thank you thank you to Bose
nuts um
my ex was a narcissist yeah you just
fell for that yo
okay this is what I'm just to conclude
I've come to conclude this okay wait
wait wait I need I need to get this off
my chest okay I have come to conclude
that either 50 of all men are
narcissists or women are all dating the
same narcissists or maybe women are the
problem no just so scientifically has
been shown uh this is the research so
let's get into data and not just these
rooms
you gotta add I'm a queen oh please add
that one I'm an independent
is it qw no k w n I need it
[Laughter]
and I feel like I need to disagree about
some a few things actually a few things
on that list actually I personally
remove I don't know exactly what but one
stood out to me now I've had a few exes
a lot of the exes I've had I've been
very very nice men
I I'd say recently I'd say about in
October I got out of a relationship and
I was with this guy for a year and this
guy was genuinely abusive does that mean
I cannot use the term like I had an
abusive ex does that mean that I like
should diminish my sort of feelings
because of that because genuinely I had
to go through like victim support and
things like that I had to put things in
place for my safety so as a woman do you
think that I should not use that because
I know you are laughing and joking and
whatnot about like narcissism obviously
I know there's only a small percentage
of men that are actually narcissistic
and I think people that ruin it is the
women that fold these words out like for
example women that lie about getting
raped or women that lie about getting us
like sexually assaulted they ruin it
let's say sorry I say they ruin it for
the actual women that have been victim
and I know again I'm one of those people
that believe in accountability I
genuinely believe that you should take
accountability for the things that have
happened to you and you should fix
yourself but I just don't think it's
fair to say that you have you should
diminish your own experience because
other women want to throw out the words
or the phrases and
again it sort of brings it down to
yourself
um thank you it sort of just brings it
down to the fact that it makes you feel
a bit worse about it sort of thing
because again I've been through things
and again I can say maybe I've not been
the perfect person maybe some other
things I've done are my fault but that
does not diminish my experience of the
things that I have had happened to me
okay can I just say yeah no from a woman
that's I'm going to speak a normal
that's been abused right in my day you
call the police nothing happened in your
day you've got all the things out there
you've got victim support I never read
it so why are you staying in it I've got
no sympathy for people nowadays I went
through a [__] so you went you went for
an abusive relationship you know what I
don't give a [__] if a man was going
through a relationships
all right you call the police if you
call the police what happens to you
because the police
as far as I'm concerned you're in an
abusive relationship the doorstep
nowadays they've got everything there
you can walk out but do you not
understand people can genuinely [__]
manipulate you as somebody that's not
grown up with the best [__]
you were young right as someone that's
not grown up you're the best Role Models
sorry it's hard for you to just click on
your own immediately what were your role
models
all I'm going to say is that you said
you were young I was young you said you
abused I was abused you they called the
police right because in my day I called
the police and nothing happened because
they were saying it was a domestic right
so we're here talking about stuff and
you're going to go against everything
everybody says I'm not going against
something I'm saying that these things
happen no no no okay no pearls just
brought up a list of words like women
but he's saying that you cannot use
the word don't stick on them
ways use and you've come up and you're
using the same thing again to reiterate
my point I clearly said to you yeah I am
a woman that believes in taking
accountability and the woman that's
healing I am a 21 year old girl I'm not
necessarily as matured as you lot or I'm
not necessarily as experienced as you're
not a girl you're a grown woman
relationship don't use the word girl
because you will say and I don't mean
this to put you down listen my mother
was raped it for it sorry sorry great at
14.
with um a weapon to her
her mother she was raised in section
eight I don't know if you have that over
here welfare yeah okay she had no father
at home she didn't meet her father until
she was pregnant with me at 30 at his
funeral when he was in the casket
everything you talk about people have
went through worse and it's not to
diminish what you've gone through
what you've gone through is a Learning
lesson for you to do better like my
mother then went on and did better than
her family through horrible
circumstances who took her in were nuns
Catholic nuns when her mother kicked her
out
from being assaulted at 14 and pregnant
that's how I have my oldest sister
so what I'm saying to you what you went
through use it as a learning lesson use
it to feel who you want to be in the
future
and realize the world has no sympathy
for any of us the only person who cares
about us the most is yourself
and you you use that as a learning
lesson to never let someone manipulate
you this is the issue that we have a lot
of times women will say I was a victim
of this and you were
okay it's not nobody doesn't believe you
or anything like that absolutely we know
the trauma and even their psychological
um I would say things that can someone
can do to you that can break you down we
even talk about Stockholm syndrome and
all these these things are very real in
psychology
but what you have to say now is say out
of all that list she said you have to
say you know
how can I now
learn that lesson so that I no longer
can be a victim to such a monster I
don't say and and you have to say take
accountability and say how am I choosing
and do I have am I purposely choosing
women in my life to guide me am I coming
under discipline and Leadership have I
made changes are there were there people
in my life that said this is not a good
guy but I still chose to be with this
person or I saw the red flags and it's
not to point blame we all make mistakes
every single person in this room has not
lived a perfect life so it's not about
um as many of you know I was just banned
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible